come sappiamo tutti ragazzi 2020 è stato
un anno meraviglioso per tutti quanti
insomma ci sono state tante positività
abbiamo potuto girare in giro abbiamo
potuto scoprire un po come il mondo con
questi viaggi abbiamo scoperto la gioia
di vivere la gioia degli abbracci la
gioia di poter respirare a pieni polmoni
l'aria tra le io ragazzi perché in
questo 2020 io l'ho passato a giocare ad
isaac decorso e aisa è un gioco che
aveva abbordato anche un po di volte sul
canale con marco berlino che mi piace un
sacco per mentre tu sei questo
personaggino vi racconto la storia
mentre giochiamo
[Musica]
allora ragazzi isaac è un gioco molto
tranquillo e sereno dove tu sei in
questo personaggio che piange la colpiti
la gente è finita colpisci la gente di
fi danno per ogni tanto premi da
mantenere
normalmente già te vai da quanti
proviamo a conte merci e vedere se
riusciamo a fare una run saluto formale
non vedo niente ragazzi questa mappa
perché effettivamente
ma non fatemi domande elencato dovesse
succedere perché
allora che succede allora abbiamo preso
quasi tutta la vita siamo solo
all'inizio lessico ragazzi boss times
monstro bene ottimo danno preso a
cazzotti ma forse questo ragazzi
abbastanza ma tanti tantissimi altri che
non è più facile realtà volevo dirgli
che praticamente alla storia di aids lui
viveva con sua madre è semplicemente la
mamma credeva e dio gli ha detto di far
fuori aida che si è nascosto dentro una
botola che sta in camera sua
e in questa botola lui si sta
immaginando tutto quello che farebbe
questo è trovato il successo tutto
questo che mi aumentate lo italia della
fine cosa molto miti letterari aumentato
ma le vetrine piano è stato reperito
sparo molto veloce di lacrime e molto
forti per è stabilito come comportino la
mente ma le skifo i ragni morite allora
prosa del v6 non è l'oggetto articoli se
ti permette di riaprire allarme ad
esempio questo mi fa cagare
beh non è male in realtà è in realtà non
è male se qualcuno ti sta per colpire
lui ti blocca non solo blocca il
proiettile ma fa danno a tutti quanti
nella stanza non è male queste ragazze
senza
meno male non mi ha colpito
questo è molto facile raga e
teoricamente non fare niente prenderlo è
una boss fight che mi chiede molto
impegnato quest'anno
allora vediamo inserire all'arno se
utilizzarlo innanzitutto c'è la stanza
di no mi fa schifo questo ragazzi
orribile lor irollo subito
questo invece potrebbe essere buono più
di me già visti da attenzione ormoni ma
che si può ragazzi sono orribile ma vi
prego e blog meravigliosa partenza
grazie a pescar di un altro partito
prendo questo ci provo da ma i jap però
preso qualcosa che mi disse conosce un
po le statistiche quindi da un po di dei
magi un po di altra roba ma va bene va
bene pentagram è decisamente meglio
mamma mia che culo che culo finale
allora teoricamente questa non dovrebbe
essere mamma [ __ ]
non è possibile non era lei potevo dire
io ce l'ho fatta
prendo c'è anche un cuore nascosto qua
lo prendo ragazzi
scrigno è arrivato il momento di morire
cuore di mamma ragazzi si sta arrivando
che faccio schifo quindi teoricamente
dovrei morire malamente ma non fa niente
proviamoci lo stesso perché noi siamo
generali il cuore di mamma ragazzi la
gente presente sono i nel dungeon sia
maturo e praticamente qui dentro
dovremmo esserci arrivati dai l'atto
ciste
eccola romani prima praticamente è fatto
ma l'iran era una cagata
sulla carta a tremare
non so cosa faccio adesso capisco vedere
quanto sebring con te lo fanno vederlo
beh
ma danno è una specie di raggio laser
putin
antica che abbiamo brimstone proviamo a
vedere se riusciamo a fare una partita
decente
teoricamente
sono buone sono diventato un piccolo
demonio però va beh quello è buono più
danno per tutte le monete che hai non è
male vediamo se va beh mi prendo un po
il prezzo
ci proviamo ma danno a tutta la scienza
sta cosa
non è per niente male
barbieri
dove metto prima di clips arrivati al
cuore di mamma ragazzi il secondo posto
prometto
per ragazzi
termale
ora posso decidere se a scendere o di
scendere non si dice così ma io andrei
di riso o di solito ho deciso di battere
satana o 10 di battere hi tech che sei
te stesso provo a buster e isaac dai
prima materialità stavolta cattedrale
ragazzi l'ultimo boss e lo stop era
fortunato dove care isaac
isaac e il personale
finale di questa che se lo trovo
mi trova niente
14 quando questo cuore la cannuccia
[ __ ] leva tantissimo sarà bene che
lo stare attaccato
gela
bene mi ha sempre inquietato dal
sottofondo distanza una ragazza sante
gente che prende cori gospel che casino
però veramente pochi quota spinale isaac
per tu sai perché non lo voterò mai però
ci trovo
vai
era un po troppo parti
ho imparato ma le ragazze attenzione
adesso non mi ha popolarlo perfetto
buono la donna che va da via bordeaux
siviglia ci sono che ha preso
qua che è proprio lui questa mega run
riesce a finire del handicap isaac mamma
mia ragazzi non è che giocata benissimo
trovo finito bella ragazza
non pensavo di vincere però un tentativo
faccia una diversa però che vi sia
piaciuto questa era una delle dei vari
finalmente sono tanti non l'ho giocata
benissimo giocata meglio però comunque
mi son divertito spero vi sentite anche
voi che sono i giochi che gioco per i
gatti neri che ho portato risolta perché
mi andava aiutato indipendentemente da
se piace farlo in meno sticazzi mi piace
farlo con lavori di stallo fatto questo
il mio lavoro e ne sono felice di yes
spero che questo visto sud e bagni
device e gli sia piaciuto come al solito
simile misura sul momento è un bel like
e noi ci vediamo come sempre al prossimo
video ragazze
[Musica]